all right this is Jeff from wacky gamer
you guys had a bunch of awesome nerd
board suggestions I'm answering them
today by asking the
cosplayer Adam West versus Christopher
Reeves Adam West Adam West and why
Christopher re uh Adam West Adam West
Adam West Adam West Adam West Adam West
Adam West West he silly he's just too
creep and he was the original Batman why
not
Superman go with Batman Adam West is not
a fighter Adam West versus Christopher
Reeves Adam Adam West Batman is the
[__] man it's plain and simple Batman
is the man Batman Christopher re he's in
a wheelchair Adam
West The Avengers versus the Justice
League Avengers versus the Justice
League oh
Avengers why um I just think they have a
more well together team than they than
the Justice League uh Justice League
Avengers got it yeah
ieng
sorry Marvel all the way I not Justice
Le that
much why they are awesome and they're
good they got a black man in the group
she I got to go with Justice League cuz
they got Superman that's kind of that's
almost a tie man yeah yeah you have you
have all the greatest superheroes
combined each other it can be basic you
can win either way I'm going to have to
go with the Avengers cuz even though I'm
dressed as Harley Quinn I'm a total
Marvel girl Justice League I
like oh man that's a good Superman in
Justice League Batman Batman y Justice
League Batman knows everybody's weakness
no matter who you are Justice
League fight Marvel it's just cuz Marvel
DC is better than Marvel you have a God
you have the uh the the AR protector
Thor Thor Thor sucks Thor don't tell me
Thor sucks Thor sucks going to have to
agree with her
okay Homer Simpson versus Peter
Griffin oh Homer Simpson's a classic I
mean he's he's been he's taking
cannonballs to the stomach and uh I
think you can definitely take out Peter
Griffin all right Peter
Griffin Peter Griffin Peter Griffin
Peter
Griffin only because he's probably
stronger than Homer but Homer has a lot
more wisdom years behind it have say
Homer my I say Peter Griffin why why
because he can p chicken yeah but more
sense it's too big of an idiot to know
where to stop Homer Peter
Griffin he is epically funny Homer just
sucks seriously Peter is a biter what
he's a biter no G Peter griffet GFF it's
two it's two against one you I don't
care I'll make Shadow CL don't play with
me you can't make Shad you're you're not
me anyway get back
here hands down hands down because he's
funny he has a fight with a chicken
you've never seen homo fight with a
chicken
Peter Peter beat up the chicken multiple
times I like classic I don't think
neither of them would fight they just
sit around like lazy slogs I going to
say Peter Griffin and why I seen him
fight the chicken that [__]
mascar hey everybody if you have your
own suggestions keep posting them we'll
be happy to answer them or address them
in the comments thanks everybody
[Music]